oh my gosh i've been so good as a
presenter at work all these years
now i don't want to mess it up when i
know millions of people are good
so what i always remind people is it's a
process there's no finish line
everybody's going to hit a wall and feel
nervous
[Music]
joe wesley thank you so much for joining
my show 20 minute leaders how are you
i'm doing great thanks for having me how
have you helped
80 000 people uh become better speakers
and convey their messages how is that
how is that humanly possible
how is it humanly possible well i've
done it for almost 30 years
and the number actually is higher than
85 000 it's because i was a road warrior
for a really long time
so we did communication intercultural
communication
and speaker coaching so i was i was on
the road for a long time working with
thousands and thousands of people
what does that mean working on the road
it means literally being on the road
moving between
company and company and working
physically with them i was i used to be
one of those uh
my 20s were spent traveling around the
world doing it
and it's kind of a part-time backpacker
and then i would land in a country
make something work save money and then
go spend it
and travel some more but then in my 30s
i was
i did corporate training and coaching so
i worked with
as a consultant so i was for a number of
years i was on the road maybe 100 days a
year
100 days a year dates all over the world
yeah it was a lot
give me you know a little bit of taste
what were like some of the craziest
places that this work took you
our craziest experiences crazy
experiences well all the experiences
were
later you learn with time you know time
and uh distance equals humor so
a lot of the really difficult things
that went on
later became the best stories i always
tell my clients that when they're
putting their keynotes together
um but there were times where you know i
i showed up to do
a speaking gig and i
you know there was no room for us or i
had a fistfight one time in a session
but in terms of location yeah
just casually putting that in there and
continuing i love it i said that too
casually but there's
when it's human behavior you get a group
of people together it's a human lab and
anything's possible i didn't start the
fight but i'm just saying like
anything can happen but in terms of
actual locations
um i i've just been really honored to
work
all over asia and europe spent a few
three months in australia working at
univer at 23 i got to work at
um eight major universities in australia
i didn't work
that hard it was fun and distracting and
you know
sunny i'm unbelievable okay so
i had the privilege of giving a tedx
talk in palo alto about
i guess it was five years ago it was
hard it was a process
it was really really difficult not just
getting up on stage which is frightening
for any person uh no matter how how
how much you don't think you'll be
scared there but the whole process
is is very difficult why is giving
keynotes or presentations so hard
well it's hard for a number of reasons
if if it's a business presentation
the average person can be challenged
with it because there's a lot riding on
it
it's it's the reputation at work it's
moving a process forward at work it's
getting your ideas heard or
helping people make big decisions so a
lot of people know that there's a lot at
stake and they feel nervous
if someone's doing a keynote it's
usually the combination of their work
experience plus a bit
of their thought leadership or personal
brand
um my day-to-day is is spent with senior
leaders
who have a track record of success so by
the time they're on stage
and we are working together at major
events
um part of it is oh my gosh i've been so
good
as a presenter at work all these years
now i don't want to mess it up when i
know millions of people are good
so what what i always remind people is
it's a process there's no finish line
everybody's going to hit a wall and feel
nervous
um i joke it is my clients usually at
one point are thinking like how do i get
out of doing this talk what if i just
tell them i
think what if i go in the witness
protection program you know all these
fantasies of not having to do it but my
job
as a as a coach is to just let them know
that's a normal process it's the messy
middle
and you know i actually have a process
to get them from start to finish
i like that the messy the messy middle
that this idea that
at some point throughout the process
you're going to reach this block where
you're saying okay i'm i'm not prepared
yet it's not ready yet
and you forget that there are a few days
left or a few weeks left and
and you're sort of i guess imagining
yourself giving the talk as it is now
even though that's not the reality you
still have time right
but tell me about this process that that
you work
because it's so fascinating to me
because obviously it is i believe that
publix the fear of public speaking if
i'm not mistaken this
is more common than fear of death i
think
we haven't sourced that research so it's
off quoted you know yeah of course
it is a common fear i'll put it that way
to this day i'm not sure if i've heard
anybody actually
dying from public speaking so most
people but it's you know
death itself is very existential but the
fear that we
we experience and the nerves giving a
talk
is real and it's likely and it happens
over and over again
so for most people um you know
it's a concern that on a
on a cellular level for people there's a
concern that they're going to be judged
that they're going to fail
yes and your body is registering an
actual threat
and it's tell it's trying to protect you
so what i
what a lot of people don't realize is
when they're feeling nervous
they will then criticize themselves for
feeling nerves like i can't believe i
i told myself i wouldn't feel this way
or i've been doing this for five years
and that self-criticism never makes the
nerves go away that's number one number
two reframing it
from i'm feeling like i'm gonna die
and my body's betraying me if you
understand that your body is actually
having a response
and it's it's doing what it thinks it's
it needs to do to help you
and then and then reframing it from
nerves to excitement
most of my clients i will say the
keynote clients that i work with
are not terribly nervous they're excited
um
they've been speaking for years and in
business
or science for a number of years so
they're they're hungry and they're
excited
and my job is to pull them out like to
get more of them
into their talk so it's not just their
data and not just their work
so so what makes a successful keynote
whether it's a business keynote
that's full of data and statistics or or
if it's more of a personal
keynote about about you know your your
personal journey or about
how others can get inspiration from your
journey so give me some
some ideas of what makes a successful
keynote yeah i put it i call them the
three r's
so a re the measure of a really
successful presentation or talk
isn't did everybody jump up and do a
standing ovation
because that's that's an experience in
the moment but i really care about what
happens when people leave so the three
the three things are the three r's
is your content relatable so for far too
long people have gotten up on stage
and spoken from a place or a perspective
that
was not taking into account the
different lived experiences of people of
color
like me or women's experiences in work
and life
so is the content relatable and do you
truly understand and respect your
audience where you're putting content
together that
that relates to them number two is your
content
something that people can remember so
you have to relate
can people remember it meaning it's
structured
effectively that you're not doing a
total data dump or you're
telling you a personal story that takes
17 minutes that isn't
relevant to the audience and then the
third piece is can people repeat it
because a lot of my clients actually
create movements they're working at
really high levels
if we're going to create systemic change
or cultural change
movement type work people have to be
able to repeat
what they heard to serve others so those
are the three things i talk about
and how do you measure that so i gave a
talk and i
went off of stage and yeah it's on
youtube and we have the views
and what how do i actually measure
whether my talk was successful and
according to these three r's yeah it
depends on
on the industry and the type of speaker
i'm working with so yes of course it's
great to have those metrics and see that
you know one of my clients talks is it
three million that's fabulous
however the folks that i'm working with
are already head down doing the deep
work and they happen to be on stage
talking about it
so the metrics that we're actually
looking at is did they get funding was
there an increase in funding
it's a business development tool were
they able to get some key relationships
that help them with their research
were they able to align and get
connections with
policy makers um so it's
it's much more tangible beyond
the applause or the gold stars
no i think it's incredible i'm you know
i'm coming from the software world and
and you know in the software world when
we launch for example our product
there's there's a couple of ways of
looking at it one is you put up the
website and you want to measure how many
impressions have you had how many people
have gone and seen your beautiful
beautifully designed logo and your
beautiful website and then the question
is how many people actually put their
credit card and paid how many
people actually converted to paying
customers which is obviously what you're
optimizing for you're not optimizing for
how many people have seen it you're
optimizing for how many people have
bought
into your messaging but and that brings
me on to
to a a set of questions that i have
because you know going through this
experience
you you watch all these incredible talks
whether it's on ted
or all these different platforms and a
lot of people are wondering as well
myself included how much are they
improvised in the moment authentic
versus very rehearsed because a lot of
them feel
extremely improvised very lively in the
moment
but it but there is a lot of preparation
that goes in there so how do you
balance between the two yeah so
that's good that if a lot of them feel
improvised to you
because the the bigger events so i'm
head of speaker coaching for tedx san
francisco so we're a premier event
global event yeah and our
our speaker there's no way we're going
to let people just go up there and wing
it
it's just not they won't present their
best content that way
and the audience won't have the best
experience you can't just take that risk
um and ted itself because i've coached
speakers that have spoken on ted stages
they work together
coaches for months and months so the
goals
what people get where they get stuck is
i don't want to sound canned i don't
want to sound rehearsed
and like i'm a rose i don't want that
either but there's a difference between
memorizing a talk and then actually
integrating that talk into who you are
and that's the difference if you're
thinking about someone who's an actor
an actor will know their lines but a
really good actor kind of disappears
into the character and you're having
they're having that experience with the
audience so
i'm different from some other coaches
because i'm
my job is to meet my clients where they
are i have
a ton of strategy in my pocket so if i'm
working with someone who i
i know is the type that really needs to
like
write their speech out word for word and
they're really attached to that
i'll let them do that initially but i'm
always going to get them from
it's not memorizing word for word it's
just knowing the flow
and if it's someone who likes to kind of
be loose
and be improvisational i still get them
to know the flow
so they're gonna put this they've
practiced it multiple times but there's
space
in the event that the audience will
laugh i mean i i a lot of
help my clients put humor in their talks
and you will get a response from the
audience or you'll get spontaneous
applause so you have to be present to
actually
engage with people in that moment it's
hilarious to bring this up i
i so i i'm i give a talk back and when i
was 14 was my second time on stage
and it was about in real time i had
nothing interesting to say except for
how if how a 14 year old uses skype to
to a do video call with their math class
from 15 000 miles away
back then it was 10 years ago it wasn't
very common
so it was it was interesting to people
in the audience but what the funny thing
was that i prepared so much for this
talk i i
am releasing a book soon where i talk
about some childhood experiences and
one of the experiences was walking
around central park with my brother
and he is rehearsing with me word for
word my speech my talk for weeks
and leading up to the talk i knew it so
well i could
i could say it in the middle of my sleep
i get to the stage and my first question
is hey how is everybody doing
now when i rehearsed this talk i never
actually gave pause because there was
nobody to answer
so when i got on stage i said hey how
everybody's doing great let's get
started
and i never gave them a way to answer
which was it's hilarious
that's what happens it is it you know
it's
i see a keynote in particular as a
living thing
so very similar to you and product
i think of the keynote for my clients
it's a product launch
so it's an iterative process we use
we use universal design theory we have
to test you have to do
all of those steps that you would do
with product to
make sure that whatever you create and
deliver
is truly something to your best the best
of your ability is something that the
audience is going to
relate to and respond but
you have to take notes once you've done
your keynote or you have to watch the
film afterwards to see what really
landed and pay attention to the
questions you get out in the comments
afterwards because it will inform
this keynote because i i help people
deliver and deliv
excuse me design an asset that they're
going to keep using
so nobody should be giving the same
exact keynote
over and over to audience after audience
because you're in a different city
you're talking to people in different
roles
different levels within an organization
you have to make it
tie into what their lived experience is
a hundred percent
so you know a few in the few minutes we
have left i'd love some pointers on
things that i could take with me to
whatever future presentations i make or
at least the process of
of working on those presentations
because obviously and not everybody's so
lucky to to have you as a coach
in preparing for their keynotes and i'd
love to get some pointers into what can
i do the next time i go
to present something to my boss and my
star in the startup that i work for what
can my friends do
when they're about to go in class and
present something in front of 500 people
on their research sure i have a five
step process i use
called dig deeper um because you can
in 10 minutes you 10 seconds you can
find the steps to give a general
presentation
you know you analyze your audience you
get your big message together and
support it with an input in action step
but something deeper that i use as a
checklist with senior leaders
is five steps so first you
have to speak the truth so
it's really figuring out what is my
truth my understanding of the truth and
do i have
do i have an accurate sense of what's
actually going on
because if you're presenting let's say
it's someone who's entry level or
you know middle management and they're
presenting to their boss and they don't
they're not accurate it's a credibility
hit right there
so make sure that you you really have
the truth and you you are acknowledging
your blind spots and biases second
it's empathy and it's not just empathy
for other people are feeling but
having a sense of cognitive empathy so
it's what what might be
what are other people thinking about and
a bit
of what's called rational compassion
because there are limits to empathy
uh we tend to empathize the most with
people who are similar to us
yeah or people if we've had a similar
experience where
we say well i did it it shouldn't be
that hard just work hard you can do it
yourself and it's like listen someone's
having a different
life journey than you are so it's truth
it's empathy
and then really thinking about do you
have an element of hope
when you're talking are you speaking in
a way where people feel like they can do
this
that it's that it's not beyond
everybody's ability
the fourth step is your vision so what
do you see as possible and can you
communicate it in a way that other
people can actually
be there right with you and then the
last step which is huge is
accountability
accountability is missing from most
talks there are real general things at
the end of a
presentation or a talk and people just
be really general like
you can do it come on and people if
people can't get a clear grasp of what
needs to be done
those initial steps they're less likely
to do
anything and that's why people go from
event to event to event
to get pumped up and it but they don't
know how to actually
do it so they're chasing the high of
being in the room
versus oh wait i want to make some
behavioral change it actually takes
strategy and habit i like the
accountability
jill why spend so much time on this
why work with so many speakers why go
through all the through this puzzles
what gets you excited about science and
so science and soul of speaking
oh my gosh i
have the best job in the world like i'm
i truly i'm truly doing the thing i love
to do most my work doesn't feel like
work at all
at all and um i stand on the shoulders
of people
who came before me i'm i'm
african-american i
come from generations of people who
weren't able to use their voice
and i'm fortunate to have that
luck yeah i've worked hard but it's luck
and timing i was born when i was born
and i feel that everyone deserves the
ability to
speak their truth and know what matters
and
that's why i do this work i love it
before we leave i want to thank you
again for being so generous of your time
this was just a
wonderful insightful inspiring i just
loved it and i'll definitely
i definitely look forward to to
reflecting on this talk
as i continue on in my journey and and
hopefully collaborate together
one day if i'm ever fortunate enough to
make it to those big stages that you
help people on
before we leave jill i need three words
that you would use to describe yourself
and and why those three specific words
okay well i've been inside the house for
months so i mean my initial three words
are like yoga pants potato chips
and tv but if we go a little bit deeper
um the first one is commitment i'm
really committed to doing the work
um i do and and helping people it's
curiosity
i've always been i've always been
curious
and willing to challenge myself to keep
keep my mind open and then i'm
collaborative because nobody
nobody gets ahead on their own and
it's really about working together and
and if you get into a big room and you
get through that door it's
keeping that door open and waving other
people into
i love it jill thank you very very much
this is just wonderful
and stay safe and stay healthy thank you
my pleasure thanks